bonjour laurent hénart bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin vous
êtes le président du parti radical qui
fête ses 120 ans on va bien sûr en
parler on va parler de laïcité également
puisque c'est un thème qui m'est cher à
votre parti c'était hier la journée
nationale de la laïcité en détention
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenarait avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bon journalisme est jalabert
jour du groupe ebra mes journaux
régionaux de l'est de la france on va
commencer en parlant de la conférence de
presse d emmanuel macron hier qui a donc
présenté mes principales priorités de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne qui débute en janvier
prochain et qui se tiendra donc en
pleine campagne présidentielle et scope
pour vous il ya un mélange des genres
qui est problématique non je pense que
ce qu'il faut c'est que les candidats
sachent faire prévaloir l'intérêt
national sur les considérations
politiques falla français a connu par
exemple des périodes de cohabitation
avec un premier ministre de gauche par
exemple lionel jospin un président de
droite jacques chirac
ils voient chacun était dans son rôle et
malgré le contexte politique d'abord
l'arrivée de la campagne ensuite ya eu
des sommets qui les réunissait tous les
deux quelques mois avant la
présidentielle ils ont défendu les
intérêts de la france
qu'est ce qui ne va pas se servir de
cette marche bien quand c'est ridicule
de penser qu'un calendrier de présidence
française du conseil européen qui existe
depuis des décennies maintenant depuis
que le conseil européen existe il ya ce
principe de présidence tournante depuis
que giscard d'estaing l'a inspirée
qu'elle me suis dans les années 70 donc
imaginer qu'il ya 13 ans parce que la
dernière fois c'était il ya treize ans
emmanuel macron aurait veillé à ce que
ça tombe pendant son éventuelle
réélection d'avril 2022 je trouve
sincèrement que ses fins elle a
découvert
cet ennemi quel chef d'état s'est démis
de ses responsabilités européennes pour
faire plaisir à des candidats déclarés à
la présidence de la république aucun
emmanuel macron a refusé de modifier ce
calendrier qui télescope la campagne
présidentielle au risque d'affaiblir les
intérêts de la france est elle écrit
dans un tribune que celle inverse que si
le président de la ligue française avait
été le premier chef d'état ou de
gouvernement à dire ouh là là là là il
ya une élection dans mon pays donc je ne
peux plus assumer aucune responsabilité
au nom de la france c'est là où la
france aurait été affaiblie et la
position défendue par valérie pécresse
en fait à mon avis le strict anvers de
ce qu'il fallait faire tu as si on veut
une france forte en europe mais il faut
laisser le président assume et les
choses et jure il faut faire la part des
choses il faut savoir faire l'unité
nationale autour de grandes causes qu'il
défendra dans cette présidence française
plutôt que de tirer vers le bas une
présidence française avec des polémiques
électorale donc ça veut dire vous dites
aux candidats à la présidentielle
combattez-les sur le plan des idées
pendant la campagne présidentielle mais
soutenait le en tant que président de
l'union en tout cas pour semer en tout
cas pour ceux qui partagent l'ambition
européenne du président de la république
veut dire que que marine le pen qu'eric
zemmour ou que jean luc mélenchon
combattent jusqu'à la présidence
française oui je l'entends mais si on
est pro européen et la ds avec une bonne
ligne de partage d'ailleurs si on est
pro européen bond doit faire l'effort de
séparer la polémique de campagne et le
débat forcément de long cours d'une
présidence française qui vous l'avez vu
sur plein de sujets la défense le
plein-emploi l'innovation l'industrie la
jeunesse avec le seul le service civique
européen propose des choses qui
dépassent les 6 - d'ailleurs vous qui
est élu de lorraine vous connaissez bien
les accords de schengen puisque vous
êtes aucun fonds d'allier réglementeront
avenue thiers aller les fameuses trois
frontières gefluc sens voilà
le troisième président à lire il faut le
réformer il faut les revoir personne n'y
arrive c'est un serpent de mer il peut y
arriver alors moi je pense qu'il peut et
d'abord il peut y arriver parce qu'il a
obtenu le commun des évolutions majeures
une seule pour mémoire je rappelle que
des sujets comme la relance européenne
comme le fait qu'ils aient une dette
européenne qui soutiennent la transition
écologique et le et l'activité
économique avec des pays comme
l'allemagne les pays rigoriste sur le
plan des finances publiques comme le
dépassement des trois points de pipe de
déficit c'était inenvisageable
il l'a obtenue alors notamment parce
qu'il a pu avec l'allemagne trouver un
terrain d'accord mais en tout cas il a
réussi à le faire et je pense que sur
schengen et dublin d'ailleurs aussi un
gars les deux glaces et les migrants a
rappelé la wii mais les deux sont liés
enfin je veux dire les deux c'est un
même sujet c'est le fait que des
frontières européennes remplace vraiment
en termes de sécurité et de fiabilité
des frontières nationales que la libre
circulation fait disparaître mais je
pense que sur schengen en tout cas
il a je crois laura politique pour le
faire et il faut qu'on y arrive il faut
qu'on y arrive parce qu'on voit bien que
ce sujet des frontières nationales
escamoté mais pas remplacés par des
vraies frontières européennes structure
est solide est un sujet qui inquiète nos
concitoyens et sur lesquels l'extrême
droite prospère vous parlez des 3%
pendant la période
manuel mâcon il a dit qu'il fallait
repenser le cadre budgétaire est ce
qu'il faut définitivement mettre fin à
cette règle et 3% pour vous alors je
pense qu'une bonne orientation c'est ce
qu'on appelle la règle d'or on n'est pas
là pour faire des finances publiques
mais vous savez dans des dépenses qu'on
va dire même pour une famille il ya deux
types de dépenses soit là il ya les
dépenses de fonctionnement ils sont là
tous les jours tous les mois tous les
ans c'est les dépenses courantes pour
celle là il faudrait que les états en
situation économique normale puisse être
à l'équilibré puis après vous avez des
dépenses que je qualifierais d'avenir
investir pour une famille acheter son
logement acheté un véhicule pourquoi pas
payer les études des enfants etc et là
il est logique d'emprunter
la transition écologique pour moi
effectivement il appartient je pense que
la défense aussi puisque manuel
maquereau a très justement dit que
j'allais progresser elles situées sur le
départ c'est quand même qu' il ya des
pays très impliqué dans la défense armée
c'est le cas de la france en a d'autres
qui sont en quasi neutralité c'est le
cas des états scandinaves donc à un
moment donné cette diversité la
nécessite aussi que ceux qui aujourd'hui
ont des budgets de défense important et
permettent à l'europe de se protéger et
d'intervenir dans le monde pour
maintenir la paix ou combattre des
réseaux terroristes notamment puissent
être plus soutenus par le dispositif
c'est ce que font les mairies 1-1 le
sénat c'est la chambre des collectivités
locales rappelle que des collectivités
locales elles n'ont pas droit
d'emprunter pour leur fonctionnement
elles ne peuvent emprunter que pour
investir et préparer l'avenir je pense
que c'est ce socle là qu'il faudrait
mettre dans les traités européens avec
bien sûr une clause pour les cas de
crise environ voit bien qu'on n'aurait
pas pu là je pense collectivement
l'europe surmonter le coc vide comme on
a pu le faire jusqu'à maintenant s'il
n'y avait pas eu cette capacité à
s'endetter pour la france l allemagne
d'ailleurs sonde était sans intérêt
les promesses des manuels mâcon ses
réformes et des accords de schengen
défense européenne il ya un smic
européen est ce qu'il n'est pas en train
de faire des promesses qui sont
intenables
je pense que ça c'est parce qu'on veut
regarder la présidence française de
l'union européenne de nouveau avec le
prisme de la campagne électorale mais
sur ces sujets là c'est des sujets
d'abord qui était dense et dans ses
perspectives européennes de 2017 c'est
un sujet d'accord d'ailleurs entre les
radicaux emmanuel macron cette ambition
européenne et c'est un sujet sur lequel
des pays alliés je pense à l'allemagne
par exemple ont déjà fait des avancées
cette idée de smic européen n'est pas
nouvelle déjà mieux en positionnement
avec vous savez des smic par pays qui
sont coordonnés que les états essayer de
rapprocher ans l'écart est énorme entre
la bulgarie et le luxembourg je crois
que c'est de 1 à 7 mais cette idée de
convergence sociale elle est
indispensable soit on veut que l'europe
qui pour moi est indispensable à la
perpétuation de notre civilisation
européenne voilà la démocratie la
protection sociale l'éducation la
culture le savoir ce qui fait que les
pays européens finalement partagent une
même civilisation
on voit bien que c'est pas mondialement
partager ça c'est pas partout dans le
monde qu'on a ces valeurs là et si on
veut le défendre c'est l'europe le bon
niveau mais il faut que l'europe soit
acceptable politiquement par les peuples
et ça veut dire qu'il faut le plein
emploi le président a raison il faut ce
que vous venez de dire convergence
fiscale convergence sociale pas
l'impression que certains en dégradant
finalement les protections de
quelques-uns arrive à être plus
compétitifs que d'autres et puis il faut
avancer sur l'europe sur la scène
internationale y compris pour la
transition écologique imposer une taxe
carbone aux frontières sa demande ne pas
être un homme politique mais d'avoir une
puissance politique juste un mot ce que
me dira l'europe acceptable par les
peuples est-ce que là aussi il ya un
message
pour la présidentielle française est ce
que du coup ça va pas être un clivage
cette présidentielle renforcée par le
fait qu emmanuel mâcon prenne la
présidence de l'union européenne est-ce
que ça va pas être un clivage entre ceux
qui défendent l'europe et ceux qui
attaquent l'europe est ce qu'il n'ya pas
un risque il ya effectivement vous avez
raison un clivage d'eau font parce qu'on
voit bien que ce qui réunit les
populistes de mélenchon à le pen en
passant par zemmour c'est d'être anti
européen et de plaider le repli sur la
nation sans dire d'ailleurs trop comment
on fait pour garder notre niveau de vie
et nos protections sociales en
cadenassant les frontières mais peu
importe en tout cas c'est leur slogan
est en face de ça depuis 2010 est
emmanuel macron assume le fait d'être
pro européens ce qui est souvent
d'ailleurs rares 1 dans le débat
politique national souvent l'européen
est honteux dans le débat public
français et je pense aussi qu'on a des
européens ambiguë on voit bien que le
parti le parti socialiste ne dit plus
rien
les républicains la liste bellamy
c'était quand même pas forcément pro
européen donc à un moment donné je pense
que le fait que ce débat se clarifient
en tout cas est une nécessité
oui la crise sanitaire aux deux
questions simples faut-il plus de
restrictions avec la cinquième vague et
faut-il rendre la vaccination
obligatoire alors
une seule réponse en fait vaccination et
passe sanitaires le parti radical a
défendu depuis un an l'idée d'un pass
sanitaires c'est parce que quand
l'épidémie flambent on doit de toute
façon prendre des mesures qui
restreignent les libertés l'avantagent
du fast sanitaire c'est que ces mesures
ne sont pas aveugles elles peuvent être
définies et mettre de côté ceux
notamment qui ont fait le choix de se
vacciner et puis je pense que sur la
vaccination volontaire on n'a pas
atteint le maximum du potentiel
en france souvent on fait bien 80 % du
chemin on arrive à imaginer des systèmes
quasiment industriel géniaux pour les
grandes masses prenat du mal à faire les
20% restants est-ce que là il faut
prendre les personnes une par une la
vaccination ça a été ça des vaccinés
drôme qui ont fonctionné quand même et
aujourd'hui une france qui est dans les
pays les mieux vacciner du monde est en
tout cas les mieux vacciner d'europe
mais on le sait encore même chez les
plus âgés des gens qui ne sont pas
encore vaccinés et qui sont pas
forcément anti vaccins entre guillemets
simplement on n'a pas pris le temps de
leur expliquer de les convaincre et
là-dessus la médecine de ville comme on
dit le médecin de famille le pharmacien
de quartier doivent être beaucoup plus
mobilisés je pense que c'est la marge de
progrès qu'on a pour la troisième dose
puisse être massive et donc nous aider à
combattre d'abord la maladie puisque
vous rappeler que la vaccination sauvent
des vies et nous protège
individuellement et puis ralentit la
propagation ça n'empêche pas la
contamination mais on sait que ce
gouvernement il a mal géré ce dernier
kilomètre on a bien non ça veut dire que
on embraye très vite finalement la
troisième dose sur la deuxième et enfin
on allait rentrer dans ce travail de
dentellière si je puis dire que on a une
cinquième vague vous l'avez dit massive
à l'échelle planétaire et en europe tout
particulièrement je suis voisins de
l'allemagne je vois la vitalité de la de
l'épidémie de l'autre côté de la
frontière outre-rhin et on doit tout de
suite rempiler une nouvelle campagne de
vaccination peut-être plutôt que ce
qu'on pouvait penser et je pense qu'il
faut réussir les deux jolies je pense
que l'allié du gouvernement pour le
faire au delà de l'hôpital au delà des
pompiers au delà des des associations de
protection civile qui font les
vaccinodromes c'est la médecine de ville
il faut la mettre tout de suite au moins
justement un mot sur l'hôpital puisque
plusieurs titres de presse quotidienne
régionale ce matin alerte sur la
situation des hôpitaux est ce que là il
ya un problème
chapiteau non mais d'abord on peut pas
tirer les leçons de la crise sanitaire
alors qu'on est encore en crise
sanitaire enfin pardon mais je veux dire
oui mais le sujet de l'hôpital c'est la
régulation comptable la régulation
comptable c'est par emmanuel macron
qu'il a enclenché la régulation
comptable de l'hôpital public et même
des cliniques privées
c'est la t2a la tarification à
l'activité saas est une norme qu'à 20
ans et qui n'a été contestée ni par les
gouvernements de droite ni pas les
gouvernements de gauche qui se sont
succédé c'est même le gouvernement les
gouvernements de françois hollande parce
qu'aujourd'hui le ps s'émeut de la
régulation comptable de l'hôpital mais
qui a inventé les fameux copper no1 ces
comités qui font que l'hôpital n'a pas
d'investissement s'il n'est pas les
équilibres comptables ce qui veut dire
qu'il faut faire la rigueur et la
suppression de lits avant d'imaginer ce
moderniser ce que j'ai connu d'ailleurs
pour les chu nancy ce que j'ai combattu
comme maire à l'époque donc ce sujet là
emmanuel macron il en hérite on peut
penser ce qu'on veut du ségur de la
santé sûrement que des choses sont à
faire encore en plus mais en tout cas
c'est la première fois qu'un plan
programmé
d'investissements et de crédits de
fonctionnement public sur le dispositif
de santé il ya d'autres choses à
imaginer à la tête on est pour une
décentralisation et de santé notamment
le pouvoir régional en matière de santé
mais mais mais je crois que c'est sa
dernière chose sur l'hôpital je rappelle
que si vous prenez la courbe il ya un an
la courbe de contamination et la courbe
d'occupation des urgences le taux
d'occupation des urgences il ya un an
n'avait rien à voir avec aujourd'hui ce
qui veut dire que la vaccination a bien
un effet positif sur l'occupation à la
saturation des urgences il ya un an
c'était plein or justement le parti
radical est très attaché à la
décentralisation
l'assemblée va examiner la loi dite 3ds
après le sénat
ça me commencé
sur ce quinqua on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
décentralisation c'est un vide alors en
tout cas c'est le oui c'est on sait bien
que c'est le sujet sur lequel
pour les radicaux en tout cas qui
croient dans la décentralisation le
travail reste à faire
je rappelle aussi qu'en 2017 quand
emmanuel macron est élu président de la
république à l'époque donc je participe
aux travaux notamment de la mf ou de
france urbaine en tant que maire de
nancy les élus sortait des lois de
l'anglais loi font pas rentrer dans le
détail mais la loi notre et le
redécoupage des régions dans l'est c'est
le sujet alsacien assez ça s'était très
mal passé donc il y avait une demande
des élus locaux qui était de dire
arrêtez de tripatouiller l'organisation
des collectivités locales et surtout les
finances des collectivités locales faut
rappeler quand même que hollande c'est
30% de dotations de l'état en moins pour
les collectivités ça ne s'était jamais
fait 1 que l'état donne des compétences
ou laissent les collectivités exercer
des compétences à sa place mais retire
l'argent qui va avec ça s'était jamais
vu enfin sur donc il ya eu quand même
une stabilisation des moyens d'état a eu
la volonté d'essayer de stabiliser aussi
dispositif législatif je pense que ce
qui est devant nous c'est une vague
massive de décentralisation voilà si on
veut que le pays au delà de la relance
renoue avec la croissance durable avec
une forme de prospérité il faut qu'ils
aient des initiatives locales et il faut
arrêter de passer une compétence et un
financement d'une collectivité à une
autre ce qui a été fait dans les
dernières lois de décentralisation ou
c'est pas l'état qui donne aux
collectivités
en fait c'est l'état qui prend une
collectivité pour donner une autre les
départements vers les métropoles
de la commune vers l'intercommunalité
des collectivités départementales et
intercommunales vers la région voilà là
il faut massivement décentralisée au
bloc communal sur le cadre de vie et aux
régions sur tout ce qui touche aux
politiques de l'emploi à la transition
écologique aux transports pas seulement
le train mais aussi la route et la voie
d'eau je crois que c'est avec cet effort
massif vers le pouvoir régional et
communal qu'on arrivera à relancer aussi
le pays durablement qui est un sujet qui
est également cher à votre parti hier
c'était la journée de la laïcité est ce
qu'aujourd'hui la laïcité est en danger
dans l'entrepont oui alors n'a jamais le
petit que celle sur le radicalisme parce
que c'est vrai que peu de parties
finalement on que sais-je qui leur est
consacré et c'est le cas du parti
radical et vous le dis dans notre
histoire depuis 1905 et avant 1905 pour
que cette idée soit la loi les radicaux
ont défendu la laïcité et souvent nous a
pris un peu pour des gardiens de musée
donc c'est d'avoir eu si tu es bon
d'accord enfin maintenant c'est fini
quoi je veux dire c'est fait un l'église
est séparée de l'état en oubliant que
c'était finalement l'idée que l'état
garantissait la liberté de conscience
individuelle protéger des prosélytisme
protéger des intégrismes protéger des
extrémismes qui peuvent être portés
notamment bien sûr par la conviction
religieuse ce qui est quelque chose de
très profond que je respecte mais qui
peut du moment qu'elle est utilisée à
des fins politiques et parfois des fins
guerrières on voit avec le terrorisme
islamiste provoqué de graves dégâts
humains et la laïcité ça reste une
valeur d'actualité c'est clair pour nous
il est menacé moi je suis très heureux
que le président de la république et
finit sur la laïcité a redonné sa
doctrine que ça aboutisse notamment à
des progrès je pense à tout le travail
qu'avait fait nathalie delattre
sénatrice radicale ici
dans la dans la mission de lutte contre
contre les intégrismes pour parler par
exemple de du dévoiement des
associations de l'ade 1901 par des
intégristes pour du prosélytisme
religieux et du fait qu'il fallait
ramener la laïcité dans le rapport entre
la puissance publique et le monde
associatif
c'est charte de la laïcité on les
voulait elles sont portées maintenant
par la législation de la république a
doit être porté par les élus locaux
c'est un progrès on propose d'autres
choses notamment sur la formation des
agents sur des choses plus strictes
encore en matière scolaire sur notamment
les accompagnant des sorties scolaires
quand on est dans le temps scolaire
voilà il ya encore des choses à faire
pour rappeler les principes et elles
sont toutes des choses à faire pour
faire vivre le principe je terminerai
par là il faut aider les élus locaux et
des les fonctionnaires quand ils sont
face à un problème de laïcité dont ils
n'ont pas a priori la solution ils ne
sont pas suffisamment
il faut avoir un appui formation
sensibilisation conseil réponse
médiation et ça c'est le rôle je crois
de l'état de franchir cette étape
supplémentaire et puis si tu es au
travail aussi les chefs d'entreprise sur
ces sujets de diversité religieuse de
laïcité sont très démunis et on l'a vu
notamment à un moment donné que débats
sur l'art et baby loup le droit du
travail aujourd'hui ce sujet-là
burqini faut l'interdire mais le sujet
est tranchée par la constitution le port
du voile dans la rue il est autorisé ce
qui dissimule le visage pour des raisons
de sécurité le niqab la burqa c'est
interdit je pense que ce sujet-là la
législation trouver un point d'équilibré
est clair le sujet maintenant c'est de
permettre à ceux qui ont des
responsabilités dans la vie sociale
d'appliquer le principe de laïcité et je
trouve que dans le monde du travail
c'est un vrai sujet votre parti fête ses
120 ans et le plus vieux parti de france
qu'est ce que vous apportez aujourd'hui
à la vie politique est ce que votre
parti pas encore où c'est en partie pour
l'histoire alors c'est un parti qui doit
grandir c'est clair que parti radical a
pas aujourd'hui la place au parlement et
dans la vie publique qu'il a pu avoir
sous la troisième ou la quatrième
république ça on peut pas le contester
mais c'est un parti qui a son actualité
parce que ce qu'on apporte aujourd'hui
c'est les racines d'un mot montée de
l'abstention montée du populisme et des
extrémismes on voit que c'est un
phénomène inexorable depuis dix ou
quinze ans ce phénomène à mon avis il
est nourri par le fait que les français
ont un paysage politique complètement
déracinés complètement hors seul
maintenant les partis ce sont des
écuries présidentielles à chaque
échappée épopée aventure présidentielle
un parti ou en tout cas un changement de
nom un changement de ligne un changement
de valeur un changement d'idée ce qui
fait un peu en train de décrire ce qui
se passait à la république en marche ce
qui s'est passé avant surtout au parti
socialiste et à l'ump et c'est ce qui a
amené ces deux partis qui étaient des
parties pivot à ne plus l'être il faut
accepter que tout le paysage soit des
racines elle je parle pas d'une
évolution de quelques mois hélas je
parle d'une évolution grandement
influencé par le quinquennat qui fait
que le parlement n'existe quasiment plus
parce qu'on on y lit l'assemblée dans la
foulée du président et donc on laisse le
président on donne la majorité au
président peu importe mais on aboutit à
une élection nationale faire une
élection par dans la semaine est édictée
finalement par la présidentielle je
pense qu'il faut revenir à des partis
qui sont des philosophies et des
courants politiques qu'on sache où vous
êtes que contient un débat d'actualité
on sache où vous attendre sur quelle
position et ses racines politiques
saissac apporte les radicaux alors on
n'est pas le seul courant de pensée il
ya le gaullisme est le bonapartisme ya
libéralisme a craqué démocratie le
socialisme communisme on nous connaît le
seul parti qui s'identifie s'ils n'ont
pas une écurie présidentielle mais un
courant de pensée qui est celui de
l'humanisme laïc
la maison
c'est l'objet du congrès qui se déroule
à partir de cet après midi et demain
toute la journée que de faire le choix
présidentiel est derrière le choix
d'alliances politiques donc oui vous
avez envie de pour ma part j'ai proposé
aux radicaux apprécié c'est un parti on
discute beaucoup on vote quand même
voilà c'est dans les gènes de la maison
donc mais j'ai proposé qu'on soutient
emmanuel macron qui est pour moi le
candidat je l'espère à venir qui est le
plus proche des principes que nous
défendons on a évoqué l'europe on
pourrait évoquer le dépassement du
clivage droite gauche ou la volonté de
trouver un modèle de croissance
équilibrée entre l'économique et le
social
et puis d'entrée évidemment dans ce
qu'on appelle la maison commune ensemble
citoyens puisque ça n'est pas un nouveau
parti mais que c'est une alliance de
partis respectent et reconnue et
d'ailleurs les radicaux veulent dans la
perspective des législatives
obtenir à l'assemblée nationale un
groupe parlementaire pour être beaucoup
plus fils notre étiquette politique est
radical à l'assemblée nationale et puis
garder bien sûr le groupe rdse au sénat
puis on est au sénat dont je n'oublie
pas ce groupe historique des radicaux au
sénat d'ailleurs je crois le groupe le
plus le plus ancien du sénat c'est un
groupement des babouins partis ont déjà
beaucoup c'est un parti on claque des
portes aussi visiblement puisque
bertrand pancher annonce son départ du
parti s'était mis en retrait alors ses
idées il part passer ça il s'est mis en
retrait bon ils critiquent votre choix
de rallier emmanuel macron d'adhérer
visiblement à la maison commune dit que
c'est la fin de notre indépendance est
ce que c'est le cas moi je pense que on
est indépendants aussi quand on fait des
choix voilà on peut pas regarder la
présidentielle passée et pas avoir
d'avis ou encore mieux choisir le
candidat qu'on va soutenir à dix jours
du scrutin parce qu'on se dit là les
sondages peuvent plus se tromper voilà
c'est pas une façon d'exercer sa
responsabilité politique après je
comprends que bertrand penchèrent
préside un groupe liberté et territoires
à l'assemblée nationale qui est un
groupe on va dire
très hétérogène avec beaucoup de
diversité donc je pense que le président
du groupe qu'il est doit être
complètement neutre en fait il ya
quasiment autant de choix présidentiel
cad membres du groupe et je pense que
s'il veut rester président du groupe il
n'a pas le choix il faut qu'il se mette
en retrait je respecte sa décision et je
lui dis d'ailleurs que la maison est
toujours ouverte pour lui une fois je
l'espère et emmanuel macron a été réélu
oui et donc vous allez adhérer à la
maison commune selon toute vraisemblance
si votre parti et le vote valérie
pécresse elle n'est pas même pour vous
de rassembler la droite
mais le problème est qu'on est passé
d'un débat avec des personnalités pour
la présidentielle puisque xavier
bertrand ou valérie pécresse avait
quitté l'est républicain a de nouveau en
débat deux parties puisque tout le monde
a réintégré les républicains et on voit
que maintenant c'est l'appareil
républicain ou eric ciotti a une
influence en fait dominante trop fort
pour vous par rapport aux convictions
des radicaux wits trop forte parce que
eric ciotti il est quand même plus
proche
d'eric zemmour il le revendique lui-même
que deux formations centristes comme le
parti radical ou comme les formations de
la majorité présidentielle donc
aujourd'hui s'ils voulaient le sujet
n'est plus un sujet de candidature
candidates ou candidats c'est un sujet
de parti on a quitté l'ump parti radical
il ya dix ans sous l'impulsion de jean
louis borloo parce qu'on ne voulait pas
participer à l'époque à la dérive
buisson l'identité nationale et les
propos sur le droit d'asile ou
l'immigration
je pense qu'on est encore dans cette
dérive quand on court derrière eric
zemmour et marine le pen bien sûr eric
zemmour juin dernier mot droite pour
vous oui je crois que c'est l'extrême
droite à partir du moment où vous
stigmatisez et où vous pensez que
l'action publique doit être tournée
contre des catégories de français ou
d'habitants en france plutôt que de
proposer des projets qui rassemble à
vous sortez du champ de la république
qui est un projet vivant de
rassemblement et vous entrez dans le
champ des extrémismes maria l'extrême
gauche moreau riches c'est mélenchon et
le riz je suis débuts difficiles à
définir et puis à l'extrême droite mort
à l'étranger et ses mots participe pour
moi de cette démarche merci beaucoup
merci laurent hénart était notre invité
est on signale on l'a montré un qu'à
l'occasion des 120 ans de votre parti a
donc été réédité ce que sèche sur le
radicalisme n'est signé claude nicolas
merci d'avoir été notre invité m
[Musique]